foreign
yourself
good morning dear colleagues can I ask
you to take your seats
good morning
I am very pleased
this morning
to welcome the president of the European
commission can I please ask you
to take your seats for this
important occasion
I am very pleased to welcome the
president of
the European commission Ursula
Wonderland to our European Parliament
for the annual state of the European
Union Address
over the last years we have
overcome
a financial crisis a pandemic
we have gone through brexit and found
new ways forward we have stood up and
stood firm
against Russia's illegal and brutal
invasion of Ukraine we are addressing
the climate emergency we have disengaged
from toxic Russian energy and we have
set the foundation for years to come the
European union today is stronger and
more united than ever before
the world is changing and Europe must
adapt and change with it too we must
keep striving to make our place our
Europe a place of equality of
opportunity of access of
Prosperity where everyone can reach
their potential we must keep reforming
so we have come
a long way but even so too many people
across
our Union are still struggling too many
women still face unfair barriers to many
of our young people still face an
uncertain future we need to keep our
people's concerns at the center of all
our actions and to underline how we will
do that it is truly my pleasure
to introduce the president of the
European commission to deliver
her 2023 state of the European Union
address which for the first time I am
extremely proud to say will be
interpreted in international sign
language
the floor is yours
[Applause]
thank you very much Madam president
ministers
honorable members
in just under 300 days
Europeans will take to the polls in our
unique and remarkable democracy
as with any election it will be the time
for people to reflect on the state of
our Union
and the work done by those that
represent them
but it will also be a time to decide on
what kind of future
and what kind of Europe they want
among them will be millions of
first-time voters
the youngest of them
were born in 2008 the economic and
financial crisis
as they stand in that polling Booth they
will think about what matters to them
they will think about the war that rages
at our borders
or the impact of destructive climate
change
about how artificial intelligence will
influence their lives
or their chances of getting a house
or job in the years ahead
our reunion today reflects the vision of
those who dreamed of a better future
after World War II
a future in which a union of Nations
democracies and people
work together to share peace and
prosperity
they believe that Europe was the answer
to the call of History
and when I speak to the new generation
of young people today
I see that same vision for a better
future
that same burning desire to build
something better
that same belief that in a world of
uncertainty
Europe once again must answer the call
of History
and that is what we have to do together
this starts with earning the trust of
Europeans
to deal with aspirations and anxieties
and in the next 300 days we must finish
the job that they entrusted us with
I want to thank this house
for its leading role in delivering on
the most ambitious Transformations this
Union has ever embarked on
when I stood in front of you in 2019
with my program for green a digital and
geopolitical Europe
I know that some had doubts
and that was before the world turned
upside down with a global pandemic and a
brutal war on European soil
but look at where Europe is today
we've seen the births of a geopolitical
union supporting Ukraine
standing up to Russia's aggression
responding to an assertive China
Investing in Partnerships
we know have now have a European green
deal as a centerpiece of our economy and
unmatched in ambition
we have set the path for digital
transition to become Global Pioneers in
online rights
we have the historic Next Generation EU
combining 800 billion euros of
investment and reform and creating
decent jobs for today and tomorrow
we have set the building blocks for a
health union
helping to vaccinate an entire continent
and large parts of the world
we've started making ourselves more
independent
in critical sectors like energy chips
and raw materials
I would also like to thank you
for the ground breaking and pioneering
work we did on gender equity
as a woman
this means a lot to me
we've concluded files that many thought
would be blocked forever
like the woman on boards directive
and the historic accession of the EU to
the Istanbul convention
with the directive on paid transparency
we have cast into law the basic
principle
that equal work deserves equal pay
there is not a single argument why for
the same type of work a woman should be
paid less than a man
but our work
is far from over
and we must continue pushing for
Progress together
I know this house supports our proposal
on combating violence against women
and here too
I would like that we cast into law
another basic principle
no means no
there can be no true equality without
freedom from violence
and thanks to this Parliament
to member states and to my team of
Commissioners
we have delivered over 90 percent of the
political guidelines I presented in
2019.
together we have shown that when Europe
is bold and United
it gets things done
and our work is far from over so let's
Stand Together
let's deliver today and prepare for
tomorrow
honorable members
four years ago
the European green deal was our answer
to the call of History
and this summer
the hottest ever on record in Europe was
a stark reminder of that
Greece and Spain were struck by ravaging
wildfires
and were hit again only a few weeks
later by Divas dating flood
and we saw the chaos and Carnage of
extreme weather from Slovenia to
Bulgaria and right across our Union
this is the reality of a boiling planet
European green deal was born out of this
necessity
to protect our planet
but it was also designed as an
opportunity
to preserve our future prosperity
we started this mandate by setting
long-term perspective with the climate
law and the 2050 goals
we shifted the climate agenda to being
an economic one
and this has given clear sense of
direction
for investment and innovation
and we have already seen this gross
strategy delivering in the short term
Europe's industry is showing every
single day that it is ready to power
this transition
proving that modernization
and decarbonization can go hand in hand
in the last five years the number of
clean steel factories in the European
Union has grown from zero
to 38.
we're now attracting more investment in
clean hydrogen than the United States
and China together
and tomorrow I will be in Denmark with
prime minister meta Frederickson to see
that Innovation firsthand
we will Mark the launch of the first
container ship powered by Clean methanol
made with solar energy
this is the strength of Europe's
response to climate change
the European green deal provides the
necessary frame incentives and
investment but it is the people the
innovators the inventors the engineers
who develop the solutions and this is
why honorable members
as we enter the next phase of the
European green deal one thing will never
change
we will keep supporting European
industry throughout this transition they
can rely on that
we started with a package of measures
from The Net Zero industry act to the
critical raw materials Act
with our industry strategy
we're looking at the risks and needs of
each ecosystem in this transition
and we need to finish this work
and with this
we need to develop an approach for each
industrial ecosystem
therefore
starting from this month
we will hold a series of clean
transition dialogues with industry
the core aim will be to support every
sector
in building its business model for the
decarbonization of Industry
because we believe that this transition
is essential for our future
competitiveness in Europe
and this is just as much about the
people and their jobs today
our wind industry for instance is a
European success story
but it is currently facing a unique mix
of challenges
and this is why we will put forward a
European wind power package working
closely with industry and member states
we will Fast Track permitting even more
we will improve the auction systems
across the European Union we will focus
on skills access to finance and stable
Supply chains
but this is broader than just one sector
from wind to Steel from batteries to
electric vehicles
our ambition is crystal clear
the future of our clean tech industry
has to be made in Europe this is our
task
honorable members this shows that when
it comes to the European green deal we
stay the course
we stay ambitious and we stick to our
growth strategy
and we will always strive for fair and
just transition
that means a fair outcome for future
generations to live on a healthy planet
a fair drawing Journey for all those
impacted with decent jobs and a solemn
promise to leave no one behind
just think about manufacturing jobs and
competitiveness the topic we're
discussing a lot in these days
our Industries and tech companies like
competition they know that Global
competition is good for business
and that it creates and protects jobs
here in Europe
but competition is only true as long as
it is fair
too often our companies are excluded
from farm markets
or are victims of predatory practices
they are often undercut by competitors
benefiting from huge State subsidies
we have not forgotten how China's unfair
Trade Practices affected our solar
industry
many young businesses were pushed out by
heavily subsidized Chinese competitors
pioneering companies had to file for
bankruptcies
promising talents when searching for
Fortune abroad
this is
why fairness in the global economy
is so important because it affects lives
and livelihoods
entire Industries and communities depend
on it
so we have to be clear-eyed about the
risks we face
take the electric vehicle sector
it is a crucial industry for the clean
economy with a huge potential in Europe
but Global markets are now flooded with
cheaper Chinese electric cars
and their price is kept artificially Low
by huge State subsidies
this is distorting our Market
and as we do not accept this Distortion
from the inside in our Market
we do not accept this from the outside
so I can announce today
that the commission is launching an
anti-subsidy investigation into electric
vehicles coming from China
Europe is open to competition
but not for race to the bottom we must
defend ourselves against unfair
practices
but equally it is vital to keep open
lines of communication and dialogue with
China
because there are also topics where we
can and have to cooperate
de-risk not decoupled
this will be my Approach
with the Chinese leadership as the at
the EU China Summit later this year
gentlemen
in the European Union
we are proud
of our cultural diversity
we are a Europe of the regions
we have a unique blend of languages
music art Traditions crafts
cuisines
and we are also a Europe which is a
continent of unique biological diversity
about 6 500 species which are only found
in Europe nowhere else in the world
in northern northern Europe we have the
world natural heritage sites the wadham
sea which is a unique habitat offering a
home to rare species of Flora and Fauna
and it's a vital resource for millions
of migratory Birds
and with the Baltic we have the largest
area of brackish water in the world and
south of that we have the European Plain
we have vast tracts of more land and
Wetland that characterizes that plane
these regions are important allies
against climate change
protected Moors and wetlands absorb huge
volumes of greenhouse gases they secure
Regional water cycles
and they are home to a unique
biodiversity as well
we have
a Europe that is a continent of forests
with the mighty coniferous forests of
the north and east
the last remnants of Virgin Oak and
Beach forests in Central Europe to the
Cork Oak Forest of southern Europe
all of these forests are irreplaceable
as a source of goods and services they
absorb carbon dioxide they supply wood
and indeed other products they generate
fertile soils they filter the air the
water
biodiversity and ecosystem services are
absolutely essential for all of us in
Europe
the loss of nature doesn't only destroy
the foundations of our life but also the
feeling of what people consider home
that is something we must protect
[Applause]
Ed
and at the same time
we have to make sure that food security
is in harmony with nature
that remains an essential task and today
I'd like to express my appreciation to
our farmers
[Applause]
my my appreciation and my gratitude that
day by day they are always providing
food for us and producing healthy food
of course is the fundamental task of our
agricultural policy the task of
Agriculture and self-sufficiency in food
is also important for us that is
something that our farmers are providing
it's not an easy task
because the consequences of Russia's
aggression against Ukraine climate
change bringing droughts forest fires
and flooding but also new obligations
are all having a growing impact on
Farmers work and Farmers incomes and we
must bear this in mind
many are already working hard towards a
more sustainable form of Agriculture we
need to work together with the farmers
and people working in agriculture to
tackle these new challenges and that's
the only way we can secure a supply of
food for the future for all of us so we
need more dialogue we need less
polarization
and hence we would like to launch a
strategic Dialogue on the future of
agriculture in the EU
I am and remain convinced that
Agriculture and protection of our
natural world can go hand in hand we
need both
[Applause]
honorable members have Fair transition
for Farmers families and Industry
this is the Hallmark of this mandate
and it is all the more important as we
Face strong economic headwinds
I see three major economic challenges
for our industry in the year ahead
labor and skill challenges
inflation
and making business easier for our
companies
the first has to do with our labor
market we have not forgotten the early
days of the global pandemic
when everyone predicted a new wave of
1930s style mass unemployment
but we defied this prediction
we sure
the first ever European short time work
initiative
we saved 40 million jobs
this is and was
Europe's social market economy in action
and I think we can be proud of it
we then immediately restarted our
economic engine thanks to Next
Generation EU and today we see the
results
Europe is close to full employment
instead of millions of people looking
for jobs
millions of jobs are looking for people
Laban skill shortages are reaching
record levels both here and across all
major economies
74 percent of smes are saying they are
facing skill shortages
in the peak of the tourist season
restaurants and bars in Europe are
reducing
their hours because they cannot find the
staff they need
hospitals are postponing treatments
because lack of nurses and doctors
and two-thirds of European companies are
looking for I.T Specialists two-thirds
at the same time
millions of parents mostly mothers are
struggling to reconcile work and family
because there is no appropriate child
care
and eight million young people are
neither in employment nor in education
nor in training 8 million the dreams put
on hold their lives on standby
this is not only the cause of so much
personal distress
it is also one of the most significant
bottlenecks
of our competitiveness
because labor shortages hamper the
capacity for Innovation growth and
prosperity
so we need to improve access to the
labor market
most importantly for young people
for women
and we need qualified migration
in addition we need to respond to the
Deep rooted shifts in technology society
and demography
and for that we should rely on the
expertise of business and trade unions
our collective bargaining partners
it is almost 40 years ago
meeting
that saw the birth
of European social dialogue
since then
social Partners have shaped the union of
today
ensuring progress and prosperity for
Millions
and as the world around changes faster
than ever social Partners must again be
at the heart of the future
together
we must focus on the challenges facing
the labor market from skills and labor
shortages to New Challenges like AI
this is why
together with the Belgian presidency
next year
we will convene a new social partner
Summit once again at valduce
the future of Europe will be built with
and by the social Partners this is our
task
major economy challenge persistent High
inflation Christine Lagarde and the
European Central Bank are working hard
to keep inflation under control
we know that returning to the ecb's
medium-term Target will take some time
the good news is that Europe has started
bringing Energy prices down
we have not forgotten Putin's deliberate
use of gas as a weapon
and how it triggered fears of blackout
and an energy crisis like in the 70s
many thought we would not make it
through the winter because of lack of
energy
but we made it
we made it because we stayed United
pooling our demand and buying energy
together
and at the same time and different to
the 70s we use this crisis to massively
invest in renewable energy and Fast
Track the clean transition
we use Europe's critical mass to bring
prices down and secure our supply
just take this the price for gas in
Europe who has over 300 Euros per
megawatt hour one year ago
it is now around 35 300 today 35.
so we need to look at how we can
replicate this model of power purchasing
power at the market a model of success
also in other fields like critical raw
materials and for example clean hydrogen
the third challenge
of European companies is about making it
easier to do business
small companies do not have the capacity
to cope with complex Administration
or they are held back by lengthy
processes
this often means
they do less with the time they have
and that they miss out on opportunities
to grow
this is why
before the end of the year
we will appoint an EU SME Envoy
reporting directly to me
foreign
we want to hear directly from small and
medium Enterprises about their everyday
challenges
for every new piece of legislation
we conduct a competitiveness check by an
independent board
and next month we will make the first
legislative proposal towards reducing
reporting obligations at the European
level by 25 percent
honorable members
let's be frank this will not be easy
and we will need your support
because this is a common Endeavor for
All European institutions
so we also have to work with member
states to match the 25
of reduction also at National level
I think it's time to make business
easier in Europe
[Applause]
apologies to innovate develop and
manufacture and this is a question of
European sovereignty as the leaders
underlined in Versailles
it is an economic and National Security
imperative
to preserve a European Edge on critical
and emerging Technologies
this European industrial policy also
requires common European funding
and this is why as part of our proposal
for review of our budget we proposed the
step platform
with step
we can boost leverage and steer EU funds
to invest in everything from
microelectronics to Quantum Computing
and AI from biotech to cleantech
our companies need this support now
so I urge for a quick agreement on our
budget proposal and I know I can count
on this house
and there's more when it comes to
competitiveness
we have seen real bottlenecks along
Global Supply chains
including because of the deliberate
policies of other countries
just think about China's export
restrictions on gallium and garmanium
which are essential for goods like
semiconductors and solar panels
this shows why it is so important for
Europe to step up on Economic Security
de-risking not decoupling
and I'm very proud that this concept has
found broad support from Key Partners
from Australia to Japan and the United
States
and many other countries around the
world want to work together
many are overly dependent on a single
supplier
for critical raw materials
others from Latin America to Africa
want to develop rightly so local value
chains local Industries for processing
and finance and refining
instead of just shipping their resources
abroad
this is why later this year we will
convene the first meeting
of our critical raw materials Club
at the same time
we will continue to drive open and fair
trade
so far we have concluded new free trade
agreements with Chile with New Zealand
with Kenya we should aim to complete
deals with Australia Mexico and mercosua
by the end of this year and soon
thereafter with India and Indonesia I
think smart trade delivers good jobs and
prosperity
honorable members these challenges labor
inflation and business environment
come at a time
when we are also asking industry to lead
on the clean transition
so we need to look further ahead
and set out how we remain competitive
as we do that
and that is why
I have asked Mario draghi
one of Europe's great economic Minds
to prepare a report on the future of
European competitiveness
because Europe will do whatever it takes
to keep its Competitive Edge
[Applause]
now when it comes to making business and
life easier we have seen how important
digital technology is
it is telling that we have far overshot
the 20 investment Target in digital
projects in Next Generation EU
member states have used that investment
to digitize the Health Care System
justice system transport Network and at
the same time
Europe has led on managing the risks of
the digital world
the internet was born as an instrument
of for sharing knowledge opening minds
and connecting peoples people it still
is
but it has also given rise to Serious
challenges disinformation spread of
harmful content risk to the privacy of
our data
all of this led to a lack of trust and
sometimes a breach of fundamental rights
of people
in response
Europe has become the global Pioneer of
citizens rights in the digital world
the DSA and dma are creating a safer
digital space where fundamental rights
are protected
and they are ensuring fairness
and clear responsibility for big Tech
this is an historic achievement and I
think we should be proud of it
the same should be true for artificial
intelligence
it will improve without any question
Healthcare boost productivity address
climate change we need it
but we also should not underestimate the
real threats coming from AI mostly gen
AI
hundreds of leading AI developers
academics and experts warned recently in
the following words and I quote
mitigating the risk of Extinction
from AI
should be a global priority
alongside other societal scale risks
such as pandemics and nuclear war
end of quote
AI is a general technology that is
accessible powerful and adaptable for
vast range of uses both civilian and
Military
and it is moving faster than even its
developers anticipated
so we have a narrowing window of
opportunity to guide this technology
responsibly
and I believe Europe together with
partners
should lead the way on a new Global
framework on AI built on three pillars
guardways
governance
and guiding innovation
first God Wraith our number one priority
is to ensure AI develops in a
human-centric transparent and
responsible way
and this is why in my political
guidelines I committed to setting out a
legislative approach in the first 100
days
you remember we put forward the AI Act
the world's first comprehensive
pro-innovation AI law
and I want to thank this house and the
council for the Tyler's work on this
groundbreaking law
our AI Act is already a blueprint for
the whole work we must now focus on
adopt adopting the rules as soon as
possible and turned to implementation
the second pillar is governance
we are now laying the foundation for a
single governance system in Europe
but we should also join forces with our
partners to ensure a global approach
to understanding the impact of AI on our
societies
now see think about the invaluable
contribution of the ipcc for climate
this is a global panel
that provides the latest science to
policy makers
I believe we need a similar body for AI
on the risks and on its benefits for
Humanity
yes we're scientists but also tech
companies and independent experts
all around the world
this will allow us to develop a fast and
globally coordinated response
building on the work done by the
Hiroshima process and others
and the third pillar is guiding
innovation in a responsible way
thanks to our investment in the last
years Europe has now become a leader in
super computing
with three out of the five most powerful
supercomputers in the world
so we need to capitalize on that
and this is why I can announce today a
new initiative
to open up our high performance
computers to AI startups that gives them
the opportunity to train their models
but in a responsible way
but this will honestly be one part of
our work to guide innovation
what we need is an open dialogue with
those that develop and deploy AI
this dialogue happens already in the
United States as you know seven major
tech companies have already agreed to
voluntary rules around safety security
and Trust
it happens here where we will work on AI
companies with AI companies
so that they voluntarily commit to the
principles of the AI act before it
enters into Force because we cannot lose
time anymore
so now we should bring all of this work
together
towards minimum Global standards for
safe and ethical use of AI our people
deserve it
honorable members when I stood here four
years ago I said that if we are united
in the inside nobody will divide us from
the outside
and this was the thinking behind the
geopolitical commission
our team Europe approach
has enabled us to be more strategic more
assertive and more united and that is
more important than ever
our heart bleeds when we see the
devastating loss of life in Libya and
Morocco
after the violent floods and earthquake
Europe will always stand ready to
support in any way we can
or think about the Sahel region
one of the poorest yes yet fastest
growing demographically
the succession of military coups will
make the region more unstable for years
ahead
Russia is both influencing and
benefiting from the crisis
and the region has become fertile ground
to the rise of terrorism
this is of direct concern for Europe for
our security and our prosperity
so we need to show the same Unity of
purpose towards Africa as we have shown
towards Ukraine this is a must
we need to focus on cooperation with
legitimate governments and Regional
organizations
we need to develop a mutually beneficial
partnership which focuses on common
issues for Europe and Africa
and this is why together with hrvp
borrel we will work on a new strategic
approach to take forward at the new at
the next euau Summit
honorable members history is on the move
Russia is waging a full-scale war
against the founding principles of the
UN Charter
this has raised immense concerns in
countries from Central Asia
to the indo-pacific they are worried
that in a law less World they might face
the same fate as Ukraine
we see a clear attempt by some to return
to block thinking
trying to isolate and influence
countries in between
and it comes at a time when there is a
deeper unease by many emerging economies
about the way
institutions and globalization work for
them
these concerns are legitimate
these emerging economies with its people
and natural assets
our essential allies in building a
cleaner safer and more prosperous world
so Europe will always work with them to
reform and improve the International
System
we want to lead efforts
to make the rules-based order fairer
and make distribution more equal
this will also mean working with new and
old parties to deepen our connections
and here Europe's offer with global
gateway is unique
global gateway is more transparent more
sustainable and more economically
attractive
just last week when I was in Delhi we
signed I think the most ambitious
project of Our Generation
the India middle east Europe economic
corridor
it will be the most direct connection to
date between India the Arabian Gulf and
Europe
with a rare link that will make trade
between India and Europe 40 faster
with an electricity cable and a clean
hydrogen pipeline to Foster clean energy
trade between Asia the Middle East and
Europe
and with a high-speed data cable to link
some of the most Innovative digital
ecosystems in the world and
create business opportunities all along
the way
these are state-of-the-art connections
for the World of Tomorrow faster shorter
cleaner we need more of them
thank you
and global gateway is making the real
difference I've seen it in Latin America
southeast Asia and across Africa from
building a local hydrogen economy with
namibian Kenya to the digital economy
with the Philippines these are
investments in our partners economies
and their investment in Europe's
prosperity and Security in a fast
changing world
deputy
ladies and gentlemen
every day we see that conflict climate
change and instability are pushing
people to seek Refuge elsewhere
I have always had a steadfast conviction
that migration needs to be managed
it needs endurance
and
patient work together with our key
partners
and above all it requires Unity within
our Union
and this is the spirit in which the new
pact on migration Asylum has been
established when I took office
there didn't seem to be any possible
compromise that could be forged but with
this pact we managed to strike a new
balance
between protecting borders
and protecting people
between sovereignty
and solidarity
between security
and Humanity
we listen to all the member states and
we focused on all the migratory routes
and we translated the spirit of The Pact
into practical Solutions
we were fast and
Resolute in responding to the hybrid
attack that Belarus launched against us
and we worked closely with our partners
in the western Balkans and reduced
irregular flows
we signed a partnership with Tunisia
which is bringing mutual benefits Beyond
migration
education energy skills and security
and we now want to work on similar
agreements with other countries
we have bolstered Border Protection
European agencies have deepened their
cooperation with member states
and allow me to thank in particular
Bulgaria and Romania
for having shown the way
by showcasing best practices on both
Asylum and returns they have proved
that Bulgaria and Romania are part of
our shanghan area let us finally bring
them in without any more delay
[Applause]
foreign ladies and gentlemen our work on
migration is based on the conviction
that Unity is definitely within reach
an agreement on The Pact has never been
so close
Parliament and the council now have a
historic opportunity to get this over
the line let us show that Europe can
manage migration effectively and with
compassion let us get this work done
honorable members we know that migration
requires constant work and nowhere
is that more vital than in the fight
against human Smugglers
they attract
desperate people with their lives
and put them on deadly routes across the
desert or on both that are unfit for the
sea
the way these Smugglers operate is
continuously evolving but our
legislation is over 20 years old and
needs an urgent update
so we need new legislation and a new
governance structure we need stronger
law enforcement prosecution and a more
prominent role for agency europol Euro
just and frontex
and we need to work with our partners to
tackle This Global plague of human
trafficking
and this is why the commission will
organize
an International Conference on fighting
people smuggling
it is time to put an end to this callous
and criminal business
[Applause]
honorable members
on the day
when Russian tanks cross the border into
Ukraine
a young Ukrainian mother
set off for Prague
to bring her child
to safety
when the Czech border official stamped
her passport
she started to cry
her son didn't understand
and he asked his mother why she was
crying
she answered
because we are at home
but this is not Ukraine he said
so she explained this is Europe
on that day that Ukrainian mother
felt that Europe was her home
because home as she said is where we
trust each other
and the people of Ukraine could trust
their fellow Europeans
her name was Victoria amelina
she was one of the great young writers
of her generation
and a tireless activist for justice
once her son was safe Victoria returned
to Ukraine
to document Russia's war crimes
one year later
she was killed by a Russian ballistic
missile while having dinner with other
writer colleagues
she was the victim of a Russian war
crime
one of the countless attacks against
innocent civilians
amelina was with three friends that day
including Hector abat
a fellow writer from Colombia
he is part of a campaign called aguanta
Crainer resist Ukraine created to tell
Latin Americans
of Russia's war of aggression and
attacks on civilians
but Hector could never imagine becoming
the target himself
afterwards he said
he did not know why he lived and she
died
thank you
but now he is telling the world about
Victoria to save her memory and to end
this war
and I am honored
that Hector is with us here today I want
to thank you Hector I want to thank you
and I want you to know that we will keep
the memory of Victoria and all other
victims alive aguanta ukraina
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
members we will be at your crane side
every step of the way for as long as it
takes
since the start of the War 4 million
ukrainians have found refuge in our
Union
and I want to say to them
that they are as welcome now as they
were in those faithful first weeks
we have ensured that they have access to
housing Health Care the job market and
much more
and honorable members this was Europe
answering the call of History
and so I am proud to announce that the
commission will propose to extend our
temporary protection to ukrainians in
the European Union our support to
Ukraine will endure
we have provided 12 billion this year
alone to help pave wages and pensions
to help keep Hospital schools and other
services running
and through our ASAP proposal we are
ramping up ammunition production
to help match Ukraine's immediate needs
but we are also looking further ahead
and this is why we have proposed an
additional 50 billion euros for over
four years
for investment and reforms
this will help build Ukraine's future to
rebuild a modern and prosperous country
and that future is clear to see
this house has said it out loud
the future of Ukraine is in our Union
the future of the western Balkans is in
our Union the future of Moldova is in
our Union
and I know how important the EU
perspective is for so many people in
Georgia
honorable members
I started by speaking of Europe's
responding to the call of History
and history is now calling us
to work on completing our Union
in a world where some are trying to pick
off countries one by one we cannot
afford to leave our fellow Europeans
behind
in a world where size and weight matters
it is clearly in Europe's strategic
interest
to complete our Union
but beyond the politics and geopolitics
of it
we need to picture what is at stake
we need to set out a vision for a
successful enlargement
a union complete with over 500 million
people
living in a free
Democratic and prosperous Union
a union complete with young people who
can live study and work in Freedom
a union complete with vibrant
democracies in which judiciaries are
independent
oppositions are respected and
journalists are respected
because the rule of law and fundamental
rights are always
and will always be the foundation of our
Union in current and in future member
states
and this is why the commission has made
the rule of law reports a key priority
we now work closely with member states
to identify progress and concerns
and make recommendations for the year
ahead
this has ensured accountability in front
of this house and National parliaments
it has allowed for dialogue between
member states and it is delivering
results
I believe
that we can do the same for future
member states
and this is why I'm very happy to
announce that we will open the rule of
law reports
to those accession countries
who get up to speed even faster
this will place them on an equal footing
with member states
and support them in their reform efforts
and it would help ensure that our future
is a union of Freedom rights and values
for all
honorable member State honorable members
the next sentence is this is on our
shared interest Parliament member states
and commission
this is in our shared interest think of
just think about the great enlargement
of 20 years ago
we called it
the European day of welcomes
and it was a Triumph of determination
and hope over the burdens of the past
and in the 20 years since
we have seen an economic success story
which has improved the lives of Millions
I want us to look forward to the next
European day of welcomes
and the next economic success stories
I know this is not an easy Road
accession is merits based and the
commission will always defend this
principle
it takes hard work
and Leadership
but there is already a lot of progress
we have seen the great strides Ukraine
has already made since we granted them
candidate status
and we've seen the determination of
other candidate countries to reform
so honorable members it is now time for
us to match this determination
and that means thinking about how we get
ready for a completed Union
we need to move past old binary debates
about enlargement
this is not a question of deepening
integration or widening the union we can
and we must do both
to give us the geopolitical weight and
the capacity to act
and this is what our Union has always
done
each wave of enlargement came with a
political deepening
we went from coal and steel towards full
economic interrogation integration
and after the fall of the Iron Curtain
we turned an economic project into a
true Union of people and states
I believe that the next enlargement must
also be a catalyst for progress
we have started to build a health union
at 27.
and I believe we can finish it at 30
plus
we have started to build a European
Defense Union by 27.
I'm convinced we can finish it at 30
plus
we have proven that we can be a
geopolitical union and show that we can
move fast when we are united
and I believe that team Europe also
works at 30 plus
honorable member
I know this house believes the same
and the European Parliament has always
been one of the main drivers of European
integration
it has been so throughout the decades
and it is once again today
and I will always support this house and
all of those who want to reform the
European Union to make it work better
for Citizens and yes
that means including through a European
convention and treaty change if and
where it is needed
but we cannot and we should not wait for
Tweety change to move ahead with
enlargement
a union fit for enlargement can be
achieved faster that means answering
practical questions about how a union of
over 30 countries will work in practice
and in particular about our capacity to
act
the good news is
that with every enlargement
those who said it would make us less
efficient were proven wrong
take the last 20 they take the last few
years
we agreed on Next Generation EU at 27.
we agreed to buy vaccines by 27.
we agreed on sanctions in Record Times
also at 27.
we agreed to purchase natural gas not
only at 27 but already including Ukraine
moldovan Serbia so it can be done
but we need to look closer at each
policy and see how they could be
affected by a larger Union
and this is why
the commission will start working on a
series of pre-enlargement policy reviews
to see how each area might need to be
adapted to a larger Union
we will need to think about how our
institutions would work how the
Parliament and the commission would work
we need to discuss the future of our
budget
in terms of what it finances
how it finances it and how it is
financed
and we need to understand how to ensure
credible security commitments
in a world where deterrence matters more
than ever
these are questions we must address
today if we want to be ready for
tomorrow
and the commission will play its part
and this is why we will put forward our
ideas
to the leaders discussion under the
Belgium presidency
we will be driven by the belief
that completing our Union is the best
investment in peace security and
prosperity for our continent so it is
time for Europe
to once again think big and write our
own destiny
honorable members
Victoria and Molina believed
that it is our Collective duty to write
a news story of Europe
this is where Europe stands today
at a time and place
where history is written
the future of our continent depends on
the choices we make today
on the steps we take to complete our
reunion
the people of Europe one day Union that
stands up for them in a time of great
power competition
but also one that protects and stands
close to them
as a partner
and Ally in their daily battles
and we will listen to their voice
if it matters to Europeans
it matters to Europe
think again about the vision and the
imagination
of the Young Generation I started my
speech with
it is the moment to show them that we
can build a continent
where you can be who you are love who
you want aim as high as you want a
continent reconciled with nature and
leading the way on new technologies
a continent that is united in Freedom
and peace once again
this is Europe's moment to answer the
call of history Long Live Europe thank
you
thank you very much
thank you very much president vonder
Lyon and now we move to the First
Reactions by the representatives of the
political group starting with the Epp
group Manfred Weber